we are told figure two is a scaled copy
of figure one so this is figure two here
this is figure one looks like figure two
not only has it been scaled down it's a
smaller version but it also looks like
it has been rotated 180 degrees or you
could say it's been flipped upside down
we're asked to identify the side in
figure 2 that corresponds to side ea
in figure 1.
so this is ea
in figure 1.
pause this video and see if you can
identify the side of figure 2 that
corresponds to side ea in figure 1.
all right now let's work through this
together some of you might immediately
intuit or be able to spot which side
corresponds to ea but i'll do it
slightly more methodically in this video
just so that we can see maybe all of the
corresponding sides and points
so one way to think about it is well it
looks like the longest side in figure
one
is side bc
so this is the longest side in figure 1
and then the longest side in figure 2 is
hl so it looks like
bc
corresponds to
hl
and then
touching on that longest side that
longest side has two right angles it
forms two right angles with the sides
next to it so you have these two right
angles right over here
and then of those two right angles you
have the short the shorter side
connected to the longest side and so
that is ba over here
and so that would correspond to
lk right over here that is the shorter
side connected to the long side that
forms a right angle
and then if we just keep following that
side of the shape we then go to side a e
which would correspond now to and this
is answering our question to side
k
j
so the
the s the side in figure two that
corresponds to ea in figure one that is
going to be kj or we could say
side
j
k
and if someone wanted to say what points
correspond to which point well you can
see that
ba corresponds to lk and bc corresponds
to lh so we would know for example that
this point b right over here point b
would correspond to point l in figure
two right over here and we could use a
similar logic for the other points so
we've answered the questions the
question but the real thing is to see
well which which
sides or points have similar features on
a relative basis so i said what is the
longest side what is the longest side
where do we see right angles and
sometimes your brain might just
immediately be able to spot out the
shape if you were to rotate this one all
the way around it would jump out at you
a little bit faster that j k and a e are
corresponding sides